- All right let's talk about Bill Cosby
and why he's going free.
This is a complicated issue,
but the short version is
not that he's innocent,
but that he was effectively tricked
into waiving his fifth amendment rights
and that made his conviction infirm.
Background is this,
in 2005,
Andrea Constand came forward
with rape allegations against Bill Cosby.
This was a few years
after the incident itself.
She delayed for personal reasons.
The District Attorney,
who we'll come back to in a second,
decided not to prosecute.
Remember this is in 2005
before scores of women
came forward against Cosby.
And it was not clear that
the prosecutors would be able to get
a conviction against him.
So the District Attorney,
Bruce Castor,
who is now famous for
representing President Trump
in the impeachment hearings,
decided to issue a promise
to Cosby that they weren't going
to go forward with prosecuting him,
continued in part two.